talk about losing pnb Rock who's
somebody who you were close with
man that was [ __ ] up bro that was hard
I feel like you lost a genuine friend
felt like I lost a genuine friend and
[ __ ] and genuine friends in this
business is hard to come by yep you know
so that was that was tough for sure yeah
because I feel like you were with him
the day before maybe
yeah at the um engagement party yeah
that's where I thought you were married
because I thought that was your wedding
because it looked like you know you know
that was that was the engagement party
wow do you remember uh
like obviously PMB was one of those guys
who he recorded here all the time he was
just a solid [ __ ] dude man and he was
one of those guys like you said it was
like super loyal very like you know like
you said like a lot of dudes got that
industry [ __ ] on him where it's like
they gonna [ __ ] with you because they're
because because it makes sense for them
it benefits them at the moment and pnb
was never that guy no thanks that's a
fact 100 man that's a fact bro